so we'll begin with the next speaker um
with some deep learning this is roll off
I met roll off app icon Sweden a couple
of months ago there on the data storage
track and I'm really happy that I
managed to recruit several of the data
science speakers so roll off and
Hendrick and who I am who I think may
have spoken so there's no harm in
stealing speakers from other competent
and dragging them to yours when they've
got interesting content to talk about so
voila flem's the deep learning user
group in Sweden that's right yeah and
there's an academic and so it has lots
of deep insights into the field of deep
learning which will hear about now so
Mike and thank you I enfora for
kidnapping me from cold Sweden um so
yeah let's start up so this was the
proposed title of my talk but then I
found out there's a lot of people
already doing the language side of
things so I decided to focus a bit more
on instead the image part bit less
pretentious but what's still nice i hope
and also allows me basically focus a bit
more on the actual flag effects for tech
what is deep learning you know in the
most basic form like what I saw the hype
about and also if you want to you know
get started with this kind of new trends
of machine learning like what a kind of
things to take care of so we'll start
with a very short introduction of like
what deep learning is where it comes
from etc and then I was switch over to
some practical advice using Python to
train your your deep neural net for
computer vision for some image tasks and
how to optimize that much once you're
there so first of all what is the
blurring which is immediately heavily
debated so so one of the most use
definitions is that it's a set of
algorithms in machine learning that
attempts to learn multiple levels or
features in which correspond to multiple
levels of abstraction so this is kind of
the core I think and it connects to once
you have machine learning there's
something in between machine learning
and deeply in which we call
representation of learning and
representation learning is kind of the
discipline assigned
we think about that what is the best way
to construct knowledge and once we have
knowledge how to represent it in our
machine learning models and usually how
we view how we at least like machine
learning disciples have done this too
many races handcrafting features feature
engineering and many many years offer of
our not mine I'm relatively young but
many of my colleagues at least at the
kth University where I matted a trillion
have made a you know big career in hand
crafting features for audio for language
for whatever and we've been doing that
for relatively large successes with
gradual increase in courtesy and we
decrease in error rates exactly but then
people learning came along and kind of
blast it all of that way so the learning
basically means neural networks there's
other ways how we can do this but
generally mean we have neural networks
and we stack multiple levels of of
neural networks together um yeah this
has mostly been started since 2006 where
two papers came out how to solve the
mystery of going beyond the three layers
once you stack neural networks on top of
each other it used to be not really
possible to go further than three layers
so it basically was just like an SVM
which also have like this kind of three
levels of non regularities where you can
say you have data I want to do
transformations from the data to be able
to predict labels and I can do this in a
certain complexity so live so so
information can be complexity level to
make sense of it and as VM was kind of
state-of-the-art and also the easiest to
use and even more important much more
performance wise much better choice than
neural network so SVM rules neural
networks will not really use much but
there were some guys still continuing
the neural network research and
especially around 2006 and onwards when
it was kind of found out how GPUs
especially could be used to run these
programs and there was more data
available labeled data when this kind of
two things collided it's wendi blurring
tennis took off so basically what I said
is that
what is done the kind of good things
about this new trend in machine learning
be blurry so what I would say is one of
the biggest troubles with handcrafted
features in manual engineered features
is that they're over specified you
create them for you know your domain or
for your data set but once you've
created them you can't really adapt them
to other domains so the very
domain-specific they're also very
brittle and you just keep investing more
and more time in these things without at
some point getting much of return at
some point you hit the level of your
models and you can't really do much more
we're on the other hand learned features
which deep learning is about that you
actually outsource this hand feature
engineering to machines you say well
computer come up with features for me I
don't really care what it is but I trust
you that you know what you're doing
these are really easy to adapt and very
fast to learn as well and also have some
kind of universal represent ability that
it can be used both for audio and text
and vision even in the same model so you
can chain one model which can do amazing
things on all kinds of different domains
and that's kind of course the dream of
heart AI please step in that direction
having a brain like model which can do
all these kind of things and then mostly
when we talk about deep learning there's
two different stages one is the
unsupervised stage where we were we kick
off our all deep neural networks we
train our deep Nets it's called on a
large amount of data and this is kind of
the trick mostly unlabeled data so you
get a kind of generative model
generative machine learning model which
starts to kind of get a good idea about
what data consists of and then you
fine-tune the model with some supervised
that where you have labels for something
but that's kind of the the trick so best
of all no more handcrafted features
which i think is its kind of key and it
lets us focus on some more interesting
things it has of course on some side
effects as well maybe losing domain
knowledge and things like this but above
all focus on this so this is not
actually really true so if we talk about
hierarchical features what do we really
mean so deep learning is basically
inspired by the brain it's very much
unlike the brain it's a very simplistic
version of the brain but it kind of
works this is nice metaphor at least how
do you think we're
so we have neurons in the brain and what
is represented here is the brain you
have your neural visual cortex which
basically is how you see the world you
know through your eyes and in your brain
your closest to your to your vision you
have you know very simple actually
detector so what you see the closest to
your brains are so few milliseconds you
see only shape size of shapes and the
size of shapes together can be combined
in a kind of higher level and neurons
further away in your brain the further
away as a time step kind of make use of
this other kind of neurons to kind of
construct these things together and it
becomes kind of gradually keep using
each other in a hierarchical fashion so
this is how the brain operates and
taking this as a kind of this biological
inspiration is what kicked off deep
learning so of course this is more how
it looks as be blurring and so we have
very simplistic versions of neurons
which can be just 0 or 1 or virtually
want any value between 0 and 1 and this
is actually the internal representation
of a network trained on faces so this is
actually all these filters what you see
here are inputs are actually what the
neurons have learned to represent so we
can see here in the most down layer we
see the edges combining those together
we get some intermediary representations
which re no eyes or noses using those
together we get to the faces so this is
pretty neat and the cool thing is that
using the same architecture in the same
ids you can actually use this for you
know other domains like use it for audio
or for text etc and depending on what we
throw in the same network learns to
represent different objects in this
similar session so it can represent cars
other than shares all in this kind of
horrible fashion so basic what this has
done for for for science and also for
industry it's mostly easily seen with
the kind of audio right different
competitions in science which have been
taking place so for the first time in
2009 we see here the orange like spheres
here are the deep learning models and
before that it was all kind of other
kinds of audio based models
mfc seas and stuff like this which were
mostly used for this kind of signal
processing and in 2009 we saw that for
the first time this deep learning model
was used and it was immediately the kind
of reduction and since then it has been
only deep learning models which have
been reducing the error rate large which
also cost kind of the the audio whatever
you would call it our industry to take
over this model and adopt them for
industry used as well and this is now
for instance in 2012 Google already
adopted the burning in its Android speed
search so if you search your Android you
know you talk to get Android to give me
you know wherever I can go to a pub well
then you're actually talking to a deep
neural network and Siri just the same
skype has been doing the same for its
instant translation from Spanish and
back again etc and the same is true for
image computer vision based approaches
were in 2012 the network Alex net
basically reduced air raid by forty
percent so all the other models were not
deep learning modes but the orange one
like beat them all very much and since
then again it has been only do plural
networks mostly convolutional neural
networks which have a focus more on and
this also has meant that big companies
like Google Facebook have been hunting
down academics were working in these
areas to kind of take them into their
research labs and it also has meant that
a lot of the actual research is not so
much happening anymore in academia but
actually in research centers of these
big large companies for for good doors
whatever you much ink of it that's kind
of what it's been going on so am I still
a long time yes I think so so this is
one of the earliest pictures from the
image not competition for the paper
published 2010 but it is not competition
2012 so these are the outputs of a deep
neural network a convolutional network
so the inputs the tests are the images
and the interesting thing here is that
we can also see that even if the the
network is kind of off which we can see
here and for instance in the well
the the grill the apparently it's a
grill different type of scar it's it's
wrongly classified as a convertible but
even in its kind of wrong predictions is
still kind of sensible it's sensible
predictions which is very different from
other machine learning approaches were
you know you can be either correct or
wrong and if the model is wrong then
it's always like really really off
there's no implicit or intuitive sense
that the kind of really really make
sense well we're by these things they're
all kind of correct ish and your hope of
course that is really correct but a lot
of times also you want your machine
learning models not to be they don't
really have to be one hundred percent
correct for a lot of your products your
building you want them to be intuitively
correct so even if it's not how many
percent grade which mostly declaring
most a they already much better even if
they wouldn't be it's still intuitively
it's much better so what else is going
on with deep learning they're doing
people trying to use existing other
machine learning approaches like
reinforcement learning company deepmind
which probably most of you have heard of
here from from London actually published
the paper playing italie with deep
reinforcement learning and I will
basically show one of their earliest
versions of what I have done which is
they train the model using just the
input of an Atari game so just pure
pixels with an optimization function
saying well there is a score related to
whatever random stuff you throw out so
you can control you know whatever you
can control on the game and all I want
you to do is optimize the score and of
course it does like random [ __ ] and it
really doesn't make sense but after some
iterations it starts to figure out the
rules by itself and it starts a kind of
layer learn these features if you will
to understand the game so that's what
we'll hopefully see her if I sound as
well no no sound
you know I've have a separate okay we
don't have sound so I will pretend what
what is going on so we can see at least
here there is the breakout I think it's
cold so it's after few iterations it
doesn't make much sense after 120
minutes of trading it it can control the
lever much more so at least the ball it
doesn't really drop down anymore so it
can just keep playing already much
better than a human would I definitely
wouldn't be able to do it with the speed
and after two hundred forty minutes of
training it finds out what are the hacks
to optimize the scoring is get these
crazy things with you maroon everything
up so notice it has to go through the
top side too so that's why is it
combining this kind of reinforcement
learning of how babies also learned by
doing trying things and saying well this
is good this is bad and then there's
been other kind of interesting things
which combine image representation with
text representations which are a bit
based on these work and bindings which I
know hendrick who else will be talking
about so combining those two things
together you can actually get good
accurate descriptions of what is in the
image not just as a one label but
actually it's grammatically correct sure
you get image captions so this is one of
these approaches and it can even like
have more more complex things but i
won't i won't spoil hendrix presentation
by showing too much of this and and then
there's some other newer things one of
the new hot topics is of course video
classifications if you take this kind of
neural networks which are convolutional
known as for recognizing images and you
take some other architecture which are
called recurrent neural networks which
are mostly used nowadays for for natural
language processing which in essence is
just a time series in disguise right
language you know words afterwards if
used word order and the same can be done
if you use this for four videos and one
very reasons published paper prints is
focused on that again without the sound
that doesn't really matter I will
explain about pulling and other things
later so don't worry about like all the
different kinds of things being used but
basically what you see is that it takes
frames over
we know and it updates what it thinks
it's it's seeing so there's the top
three prediction do so top K tree
predictions so it knows that it's
obedience training for dogs somehow and
it knows even that which kind of dogs
are in their different fighting I don't
know how it knows that this is sistema
already from the start but burns it nose
or cough mega Mountain unicycling
adventure racing so that's pretty
awesome and so on and this of course
allows for really interesting approaches
also for having you know much more Ritz
interfaces where your thinks it may be
news broadcasts which you can average
with all kinds of meta data and
information and it allows I mean you're
going to mention the kind of things this
would allow you to do on you know any
kind of visual data or video data you
have more interesting i think i will
leave it to that and then i think just a
few days ago published paper and also
blog post by by google about deep neural
networks it's kind of addressing this
concern about well we have this deep
neural networks and but we don't really
know what is going on in this you know
middle part this black box of fiji
representations but actually we do know
we can visualize these things quite well
so what I've done they call it of course
there makes a nice you know buzz word
for it sorry call the dreaming so what
does the network dream you know it
sounds very nice but what we see here is
that the input image is the left image
and the Utah the network okay well
predict not predict what is on this
image but instead of giving an output on
your final layers of your network which
are just you know like a logistical
regression at the ends of some softmax
classifier where you say well what is
the matching label you know the what is
the Y to X you say well in this
intermediate in your first layer what do
you think you see
so visualize what are your kind of
thoughts neural network and what you can
see is that well actually it starts to
reconstruct the image by edges with the
first layer does you have an edge
detector and if you do the same for for
further away layer so let's say one of
the last layers you get the different
kinds of concept it comes up with with
in this case it's a cloud so what at
things that is most logically assumed to
be in clouds are birds so these are kind
of work you can't really see it but if
you zoom in you can see it some kind of
bird like fashion so this basic means
that you can find out more the logic
reasoning of your of your neural network
what it comes up with in and how does it
arrive to its decisions so it's
definitely still in a good direction at
least of getting understanding of like
how do you think work then you can take
it to the other level you can say well
we do it in different iterations so we
keep using the output image of this
dreaming as the input image and we do
this over multiple it races and we get
all kinds of expressionist art so we
don't really know what is the input
image anymore but it looks pretty
awesome and this is totally constructed
by a neural network trained on thousand
classes of different kind of images and
what it knows and recreate them and
that's kind of cool so how does neural
deep blue how does deep learning work
done so we know we have neurons which
you know are basically quite complicated
things but if we optimize them or or
convert them to some mathematical
expression instead we get some simple
formulas where we have an input we have
some weights attached to those inputs we
have some activation function in the
middle which you know the most simple
form here it's a linear regression but
of course we can put in all kinds of
other things and then we have have an
output and this is in all the different
neurons of the neural network you have
this kind of different logistic
regressions or whatever you want to
throw in there and one of the most
important things to do here is to think
about your activation from functions or
the things in the middle so
what do you throw in here you want to
convert values mostly 01 you know if you
talk about normalized pixels of between
0 and 1 to some kind of intermediate
output so they can keep you know coming
up with with the stuff they like to come
up with and the earliest use function
was simple sigmoid which is a kind of
non-linearity to convert like it
basically very continuous values to a
kind of discrete value and here you come
up with things which are basically
squashes your input to a number between
0 and 1 but there's a problem that is
not 0 centered and there's all kind of
these problems the tester I won't go
into so instead then what people have
done they come up with hyperbolic
tangent and which means you squash it to
between minus 1 and 1 so you allow your
network to be more rich in a
representation while still being you
know mathematically quite simple and
fast to compute but still it's not 0
centered and it still does kind of
unintended things you don't want to do
like it kills the gradient the
derivative basically of your input and
this is done one function mostly you so
if you want to start training neural
networks is mostly what your wheels and
it's commonly known as the rectified
linear function but it's also mostly
approximated which is why it converges
really fast like this is four to six
times faster than any of you other
functions so basically just a min max
function so what do you mean when we
when we convert so if we perceive you
know the output of your inner Annette
work is you know the the error range
there so you have two different error
dimensions to the left and you say well
you start somewhere and you take
iterations and it crawl slowly towards
you know your your optimum minimum of
your of your error from your activation
function of your loss function then that
basically where you wanted to end up and
this is of course a very simplistic
version of it but this is going to be
the different optimization strategies
you can take for that so you have but
we'll all probably know stochastic
gradient descent which is one way and
then you are all this kind of momentum
which you can plug in on your [ __ ]
getting this on to make it go a bit
faster and all this other more
probabilistic methods so it's going to
first order optimization strategies so
that's all for for the theory so hope
we're all here still with me so what's
there for Python them if you want to
really do some coding with most of you
probably are more interested in so for
Python we have actually a lot of
libraries from most low level we have
toyou know which is basically numpy on
steroids so it can do gpu-based
computations it's heavily optimized for
that cafe it has pie tin rappers but you
most you will be using the architectural
layers and 44 computer vision mostly and
cafe is really good in the sense that it
has what they call the model zoo so it
has a lot of models which are already
readily available so kind of the winning
model at the image net competition or
some of the more recent models like the
Oxford you know whatever it's all on
there so you can just download the model
and even more so you can download the
pre current model so you don't have to
train and spend some some you know a few
hundred bucks on training this neural
network for yourself for a few weeks
where you can just start with a
pre-event model to at least you know
understand what it's doing and maybe
plug in some other stuff on top of it so
this is one thing I've done and you can
i have a link at the end so I've done
for short for the bike on data often so
I show them the Python Sweden converse
or basically use one of the Praetorian
models cut off the top layer put some
new classifier on top so I said instead
of you know you i want you to predict
one out of a thousand different classes
i want you just to predict if something
is a cat or a dog and then you know took
off with that image trained in one hour
inside of you know that i have to train
it on for two weeks then there is a py
learn which is wrapper for taeyeon oh
and then there's chaos on lasagna which
is renewable variance which again are
also represent diana and the examples i
use will be lasagna based kind of course
some sites guy could learn and this is
also the links
you
um
so we started a bit later I'm not sure
to what time I have fine okay then then
we're still good so for for doing the
deep learning if you really want the
details about you know how to do the
actual coding part I would you know
advise you to look at some other
presentations or stuff but if you have
started these things works are done kind
of things to look at so first of all you
have your data which you probably want
to pre processing some some smart way
you need matching architecture with your
your you know you think you want to do
let's say you want to do some stuff on
images then you have to actually train
the network once you've chosen the
architecture and then you want to
optimize regularize it depending on what
the output is you won't do it kind of
test it and get some feedbacks so to
pre-press we process the data which with
deep learning at you want to do as less
as possible because the more the more
transformations you do yourself on your
data like you know using sift features
or hawk features on your own your image
that the less you let the neural network
come up with its own representation so
you want to be as simple as possible
with that so they're more raw the input
actually the better so what you do want
to do you want to scale the data to each
other so they have to say mean et cetera
so normally do some mean subtraction
normalization and which basically looks
like this so it's one line between I
sorry just to empty mean there you go
for your whole array and be standard
deviant also and you're done and now
it's centered around the 0 about the
origin that's all you want to do so that
your your pre-processing unless you do
want to try some other steps you may
want to do some PC a whitening and stuff
if your if your data is really noisy
this may be something you want to
consider so you do some at least a
little bit of dimensional reduction and
you make it a bit less noisy so that's
basically the code for that also still
pretty much simple so you basically
strikes and squeeze the data into some
Gaussian block basically they become
system isometric thing
so how that looks for the images once
you have the original images and you
these kind of things this is basically
what you done is that feed into the
network so you fit into the network
everything with deviates from the norm
because that's actually what makes sense
it doesn't make sense to delete all of
that so it allows the network to kind of
be more specific on the things it learns
for your different classes you want to
have and then important where these kind
of things of course is to compute the
statistics only on your training data
because that's what you're training on
but it will also apply it on all the
data because otherwise if you train it
you know on this kind of transform data
sets eels and you test it on mon
transform data sets of course it's not
the same so you don't so you shouldn't
forget that at least so that's about the
most simple form of pre-processing so
once you've done that there's well
mainly speaking this tree architectures
you can choose from there's two deep
deep belief network which is basically
just a bunch of of neurons or it's a bit
based on restricted boatman's machines
that statue anything which you stack on
top of each other introduced by in turn
in 2006 basically as a way to pre
trained neural networks so that's one
one choice mostly used for different
kinds of hierarchical data load for
audio data as well for biomedical data
you have your recurrent neural networks
which are basically a form of an inner
Marco Polo which nowadays are mostly you
know all the kind of adapted variants
like long-term short-term memory which
is mostly what revolutionized natural
language processing finally after it
maybe since 2014 when everybody else was
already doing cool stuff for four years
we were all still lagging behind until
this came along and then there is the
convolutional neural nets which are
basically used for for for Imogen and
these kind of things so convolutional
known that basically looks like this you
have an input image you have your
convolutional layers and what a
convolution means i will show in the
next slide and then you pull them which
is basically you make them to the same
dimension again
and you have your output and you have
this in many many layers you want to do
this as many layers as is possible so
convolution basically is you have an
input image and you take small filters
from that you take a smaller crop so you
take small crops but what you do is you
kind of sum them together so this is a
amex convolution and the actual convo
feature becomes a kind of abstracted
sense of what you have in this image
what kind of them ever reaches them or
Mac system depending on what you doing
so that's in a most simple form what
you're doing with convolutional neural
that's the trick so if you understand
that then you implicitly know what all
the fuss is about it's actually
relatively straightforward so then these
were networks mostly used le already was
used to the first time in 1998 four
handwritten character recognition and
2012 is basically when it started to be
adopted more in academia and also for
industry with some the most new model so
the most large with maybe you know up to
17 or 20 layers deep by Google net in
goop Lynette the winner of image 9 2014
I think the vgg which is from Oxford and
then also some Microsoft audio
recognition okay we have to hurry up a
bit
so they be actually training the network
we do with in the most simple form
basically like when we use something
like the Sonia business it this is all
the kind of code you need to start your
neural networks so this is the court so
you assign you have your layer
definitions in the beginning and then
you have your parameters which you so
you can see the filters which are three
by three in this sense or in two by two
so that's the sizes of the crops you
take and then also the pooling sighs um
and then you also have your your
learning rate which you want to set or
your momentum your output of course what
kind of linearity you want to use you
know the tongue hand or the sigmoid or
the rectified linear units and you have
some different hyper partners and if you
want to optimize your your model you
want to try different things you
basically play around with this part the
architecture that's mostly what you work
with architectural part is what you try
to see see what it's doing on a smaller
subset of your data to first right and
also with the hybrid parameters so the
things like the learning rate or when do
you want to stop so once you do that
then you start training your network you
get this kind of things you get a loss
function with the basic approximation of
the of the error and and that's it now
you're basically done and you keep
running this for a while but if you want
to debug this you can do very simple in
lasagna you bet you get not trained in
history and you have to train loss in
the bed at loss and you can basically
just plug this you get something like
this so you have your your loss curve
which you of course want to get less
over time and at some point most likely
the train and develop loss they will
start separating from each other in your
model will start to overfit more and
that's kind of why able to stop your
model so your mobile doesn't over fit
too much you can also get lost curves
like this which are very very white so
this mostly means that your it's too
noisy and you want to lower your
learning rates if you get functions like
this if it's also very white it also
might mean you want to optimize like
basically increase your bed size so the
kind of number of samples you do
you're testing on and if there are two
white against about each other then
definitely also want to regularize your
network more so your network is
basically too deep to make sense so you
have to do some more regularization or
that's your network but what you want is
also you always want a little bit of
overfitting if you don't overfeed your
model is not deep enough basically so
you want to have overfitting but as
small as possible so once you regularize
it more then you get things no somehow
it's gone but it doesn't turn becomes
smaller other things you can do is
visualize the weights so this is
basically how you start your weights if
just random noise and if after a while
your your layer is still do the random
noise of course something wrong going on
or even more after a while when your
your layer still look like this they're
still very noisy so you still have to do
something to change it so you want to
basically adapt it and the more
regularization until they look something
more like this where you have a keen in
the first layer mostly what you will
look at because it's the easiest to
recognize have to be looking like edges
so now we have an extra racket and this
is kind of the loop to do you optimize
your girl arise you go back you train it
and you keep going on until it's
basically make sense you can trick you
hyperparameters which is really hard to
do and of course if you can't really
like you can't really do a grid search
on your deep neural network with us you
know up to millions and millions of
parameters so that's that's not really
possible because you know you will go on
for you know millions of years you can
do a random search we're just having a
you know less parameters to train its
kind of being used and it works or you
can do bees you in optimization which is
a nowadays which is the most yeah it
looks like this works the best and
there's two libraries for that also
then you can also go on your data and
you can say well you can transform my
data in kind of meaningful way so
especially for images it's quite easy
you know it's a common technique to
scale your images to rotate them etc so
you have for instance random probes
different contrast flip stints which
look like this which are also really
implement and this is friends an example
of the catwalk competition for the data
science Benton ball so this is a lot of
different kinds of techniques that use
for data augmentation which is basically
why one of the reasons why they probably
won the competition because it allowed
them to basically you know triple you
know make hundred thousand more data and
then they would normally have so they
did this doubt data admin tation in real
time other things you can do is drop out
which basically once you have again
something way to work to white between
the training and the better loss
function and this is your your neural
network you can basically randomly
switch off notes which allows the
network to kind of adapt to particular
parts and it becomes kind of overlapping
so instead of having very specialized
network where every node does one thing
multiple nodes will start being bit more
redundant in what they're doing you have
a much more agile model and it will look
more like this so of course that's one
where you can do best normalization
which I won't go into now so that's one
of the other tricks and finally what
else show is how to win a kakoe
competition with only two days of coding
with of course we're all interested and
that will be the end so this is all the
different things you can do but if you
really want to be you know not so smart
about it you just roll your models
together so you have ten let's say you
train ten models and independently from
each other you can see the first thing
to each other you can see the error rate
it's kind of low until you start putting
in them all together that's the final
one where you take the average of all of
them you have a much higher because
they're all probably over fitted in some
portion of data but if you take the
efforts of all of them together they all
have grabbed at least some logic of your
data and together they do a much
job so it's kind of wisdom of the crowd
instead of having one specialist so
these are the different if you take this
the average predicted mean by the mall
or you just leave out one model the
worst-performing model you get the best
thing and for one of the Geico
competitions what I've done is basically
this is also from a tutorial by Daniel
newly where you train different
specialists for different facial key
points stuff so these were three models
I trained with a little bit of different
tweaking every model maybe took two days
to train so it's relatively small model
it's still fitted on the g2 amazon
instance so it's quite small
convolutional network and didn't cost me
too much to train in my free time but
then taking all of these together you
get a much higher or a much lower root
mean square error which is this
basically the amount of pixels you're
off on a 48 by 48 image predicting the
the facial key points and that was my my
famous glory to rising to position one
but then machine learning systems can
also be easily fooled and that's one of
the other approach is taken in academia
a lot so we can predict instead of on
the image base we can predict also
classes on the pixel level so we get
this kind of salience in maps it's
called so we have different classes on
the pixel level and then we can do our
magic so we know if we have a certain
let's say we take an input image police
van and we also have an image Egyptian
cat and we take the most meaningful
pixels from the Egyptian cat and we can
which basically is a bit like noise
that's the middle one that's kind of the
activation of the gradient from the and
we put that push that in some smart way
into the image it still looks for humans
as an imp Elise run but to the model now
it's an Egyptian cat and we can do that
the same for down there we all know and
it looks a bit distorted because it
didn't have time to do the nice you know
whatever the color space was a bit off
but now it's a cold fish
so once you see that logo somewhere on
the internet it's a goldfish and there's
other ways you can fold them basically
that they don't always perform it well
so they can be over fitted on particular
features so we have what the model their
CSS leopards and this is most likely
what the models has learned to recognize
but once we don't have a couch which
actually I think also few days was tried
in on the three train model and all the
existing commercial applications as well
and everyone of numbers off like metal
mind whatever all the other ones
predicted it all as a Jaguar and banter
yeah yeah this is it so here we go
wait so one thing i'm wondering i always
see a way of understanding what's going
in and inside the internal layers it's
through images and it going son see
different edges being detected then
shapes being detected and that mostly
applies to images but how do you get the
similar sort of intuition when you're
dealing with NLP yeah very good question
that's actually what my BD is parking
about and it's not really i wouldn't
have a good answer for that i mean in my
images that's why i think one of the
reasons why why images are kind of
taking off so much because it's kind of
easy to visualize and the problem with
language is that language it's not right
it's kind of it's simples right language
sorry and it's in it's a representation
already by itself as an abstraction if
we talk to each other what we really say
with our words is not really what we're
saying we were saying all the kind of
informed decisions which we have taken
culturally and linguistically to
understand what its symbols mean so to
have all of these models in your network
model world and i will tell a bit about
that the only only stop how you still
can get this kind of assumed context in
your model with working banks but the
yeah that's it hard to visualize yeah
thank a great talk thank you very much
when a small child tries to learn
something it's see one cat to cat ten
cats but not thousands of cats and each
be able to understand difference between
cat and dog even with size small samples
do you think that something is missing
not only some knowledge of the world of
human but but something else is missing
in this approach when you try to compare
it to his brain is human brain yeah well
i mean the the neural not stirred
they're extremely much more simple than
than the brain operates the brain is
much more complex like neurons in the
brain and take different kinds of
they're all kind of similarly doing the
same thing at different layers which is
kind of interesting but they're all
still very different there's a lot of
neurons there and also the brain is
insanely much more large in the largest
neural network at thousands and thousand
thousands of times larger so it's
impossible to compute you know what is
going on in actual in the brain and then
about the child learning things through
examples I mean yeah of course you human
brains there there you know they can do
so many tasks at the same time well a
neural network can only do you know one
or a few so so you can't really compare
them in that sense so it's such
different kinds of intelligence if you
want they do really really different
things and they also have very different
representations and one of the kind of
more philosophical aspects which are
which some people are kind of now
developing further is that you need
embodiment for for intelligence so you
need to experience the road to be able
to understand it so that were robots and
why maybe google bought you know this
robotic firms had to be be able to do
that and also what else I was going to
save us well children they learn
continuously still you know neural
network you train for two weeks and then
it's off again well if you're you know
we humans we train continuously we're
continuously learning new things
so I'm stealing time from you